someone who goes by the handle queer
surgeon on tick tock and who chops the
breasts off of minor girls for a living
is uh speaking out now in his own
defense and by the way he's quite proud
of what he does and is not embarrassed
or ashamed at all and um here he is
justifying himself
so i'm here to clarify and speak some
truths about what's happening with
gender affirming care and adolescence
most of the bills that are going through
right now aim to limit this care for
people under the age of 18. and there's
this false narrative that a lot of
teenagers are having gender affirming
surgery most of the teenagers that are
having surgery are getting chest surgery
and most of that is happening before 18
because these individuals didn't have
access to early enough medical treatment
so
using surgery as sort of this false
narrative to attack gender forming care
as a whole is not correct the truth is
that by limiting access to medical care
with some of these bills you're actually
going to cause more people to need
gender affirming surgical care
so the real headline there is that we've
got this guy the queer surgeon quote
unquote
admitting
that most of the uh the
quote chest surgeries which is uh which
really is mutilation they're just
chopping the breasts off of
physically healthy girls most of it is
happening to minor girls before the age
of 18.
and there's and he even admits there's a
lot of it happening but tries to draw
draw some sort of distinction between
um
gender firm quote unquote gender
affirming surgery and this he said oh
there's this false narrative that
there's all kinds of the surgeries
happening to kids oh it's mostly just
the top surgeries
yeah that's that's you're you're
chopping body parts off of children
a lot of them
this is currently happening
in the united states of america
14 year old girls are being brought in
and having their body parts removed
and
for all the talk of the backlash the
much needed and deserved backlash
against this kind of thing i mean these
people are still they're not worried
they're out in public talking about it
and of course everything he says is just
completely the only honest thing we
heard there is that there's a lot of
this happening and it's mostly happening
to minor girls she's right about that
everything else is total nonsense
starting with the uh with the claim this
is medical care
this is not medical care
you know if you're chopping off a body
part
there are times when chopping off a body
part is medical care
there are times when limbs and parts of
the body have to be removed
double mastectomy because of uh for for
a cancer patient okay that's medical
care
somebody has their leg horribly mangled
and you have to take the leg off that's
medical care
but when you are removing
physically healthy body parts
from a physically healthy person that is
not medical care
that is
mutilation by definition
and he also makes this claim that uh
this is only happening because
these girls are not given
uh the the medical care they need
earlier in life and if they got that
quote-unquote medical care then we
wouldn't have all these surgeries
total nonsense
not only because it's not actually
medical here that he's talking about but
also because like what is he referring
to what he's saying is that well these
girls
um who i guess he would say are boys
even though they have breasts that need
to be that he thinks need quote-unquote
to be chopped off
but if they were given uh like hormone
blockers and hormone pills and stuff
like that
then then we wouldn't be
and not enough of these kids are being
given the drugs early enough in life so
for him the solution is to drug more
kids and to drug them earlier in life
but he damn well knows that all the
drugs do and all they're really meant to
do is put the kids on the path
to surgical mutilation
i mean the drugs are not going to stop a
girl from
growing breast permanently
in fact they're the ones who always say
that it's temporary puberty blockers are
temporary
that's what they always claim
and reversible the reversible part is
also not true that's a lie so there's
just so many every time these people
speak they speak for 45 seconds and
there are so many lies that you you it's
you know it's overwhelming it's hard to
even know where to begin in sifting
through all this
but
they themselves say it's a it's a
temporary thing okay so you're giving
the puberty blockers temporary even
though even from the temporary use of
the puberty blockers there's now going
to be lifelong effects
but then you take them off the people
blockers now what
well the next step is to put them in for
surgery
that's why this guy who
makes a lot of money chopping the
breasts off of girls that's why he wants
more girls
on the drugs and wants them on drugs
earlier
because that creates the factory
conveyor belt
um of girls who are going to eventually
make their way over to him
because most of the kids who are putting
these drugs they end up seeing they end
up they end up going the whole way
they're now in the system they're on the
drugs they're on the conveyor belt and
then not all that far down the line you
get to the
butcher with the scalpel
and he's sitting there with his pockets
open waiting to uh you know make some
more money off of it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content